this card is getting excited okay good
let's go guys
[Music]
Coop's anything to do prisons people bit
whoa where you know that's
understandable don't necessarily want to
be bad people but it's about changing
and bias doing this gives us that bit of
hope that we believe we can get a job
we're human time ran once those seven
years I've got [ __ ] conscience in our
heart and I can never change what I've
done what the change was gonna do oh
[ __ ]
it's a point technically we gotta cook
and learn at the same time but I'm gonna
sell so we can't afford any mistakes
because everything they make eternal
don't throw any face your way guys yeah
every time we float pastry way try to
put me in a bit to make sure we draw in
the customers I want the prisoners
themselves to drum up some business so I
need you to put a phone call in tonight
mum
Monty tell him to get down this is 22
year old Jerome Samuels first time in an
Adult jail but he's been in and out of
trouble all his life how old when you
first hit the streets 12 have you been
inside of young offenders yeah where
thank you
just way my last night well crime in it
I'm a young age in it and I was young
and my dad died immigrant not dead my
Sigma candidates face down in it burnt
B&E and obviously I just for you know
what [ __ ] this I give up
ain't got night to lose normal right my
mom and that and shot me units out you
just give it a look
you'd do it again night the stop its
when he was gonna do something like
right
they'd have no look since been in
Brixton the prison authorities have been
unhappy about Jerome's behavior today
things have stepped up again he's been
called to a disciplinary hearing I'll
finish that
[Music]
Hot Pursuit
why they just keep it shut giant but
authority seems to mean nothing
does your own and senior officer Andy
Cole has had enough sure Oh miss charged
with verbally abusing a female officer
and if found guilty he could be kicked
out of my business for good one of the
things we know is often is that we're
usually the first sort of adults that
have ever said no to them he's not the
worst my thighs my girl but he has to
realize that he was in a head-on
establishment and he's got to act like
an adult today's hearing is in front of
wing governor neil craig a.m. well
government Craig getting this is swollen
okay you've been charged under prison
rule 51 paragraph 20 that you stay in an
abusive or insulting what is the
behavior and how do you plead to that
charge no sir and do you want any help
with this hearing yes sir
yes legal representation in it but
you've asked for legal advice I'm gonna
remind it for a week okay
thank you Zack the case is adjourned
so for now Jerome stays and my work
force is still up to strength for the
task ahead